Hola y bienvenidos a la entrevista de
France 24 nuestro invitado de hoy es el
Primer Ministro de Irak Mohamed al
sudani Muchas gracias señor Primer
Ministro con gusto Gracias
está aquí en París estuvo en una cena
con el presidente francés firmaron
varios acuerdos especialmente un acuerdo
de cooperación estratégica
pero especialmente hay compromiso de que
Francia le proporcione Irak más armas
más apoyo en materia de seguridad
en el nombre de Dios el compasivo el
misericordioso por supuesto nuestra
visita a Francia es un cambio de
paradigma en las relaciones entre Irak y
Francia y tomó un camino estratégico
realmente a través de la firma del
acuerdo de cooperación estratégica
este acuerdo es estratégico incluye
puntos que abarcan todos los sectores y
los asuntos en materia de seguridad
del sector económico social cultural
educativo
de acuerdo es enorme cubre una amplia
gama de temas y parte de esto se
refieren a la seguridad municiones y
armas
estamos trabajando para asegurarlas Para
nuestras fuerzas de seguridad para
diversificar nuestras fuentes de
abastecimiento
Por qué nuestras fuerzas de seguridad
tienen experiencia en armas francesas
hablando de seguridad Usted dijo
recientemente que las tropas
estadounidenses tendrían que permanecer
en Irak porque el grupo estado islámico
sigue siendo una amenaza
obviamente algunos grupos en Irak no a
favor de esto
puede aclararlo
las tropas estadounidenses se quedarán
mucho tiempo no hay límite para su
presencia en solo ir aquí
en nuestra postura es Clara y sólida en
el sentido de que Irak no necesita
tropas de combate pero sí cooperación
con la coalición internacional liderada
por Estados Unidos y con todos los
países que trabajan y realizan esfuerzos
contra el grupo estado islámico
la presencia de la coalición
internacional es a petición del anterior
gobierno iraquí
y con respecto al acuerdo político será
a través de un diálogo político
un diálogo profesional que será
determinado por las partes oficiales
dentro del gobierno sobre la
determinación de la ubicación el número
y los sectores
[Música]
especialmente en cuanto a la instrucción
y al intercambio de información
la guerra contra el terrorismo es
diferente a la de antes hoy no hay
actividades sobre el terreno Pero hay
grupos que se trasladan de un lugar a
otro que tienen actividades fuera de las
fronteras de Irak que amenazan no solo
la seguridad de Irak sino la de toda la
región
entre la cooperación entre nuestras
fuerzas de seguridad y el aparato de
seguridad de nuestro país amigo
identificar la presencia de los
terroristas las malas actividades y
quienes los financian
por lo tanto necesitamos un nuevo tipo
de relación que se en la cooperación el
intercambio de información el trabajo
conjunto y también preservar y asegurar
la soberanía de Irak en el aire la
tierra y el mar
viaje
Entonces no hay límite en el futuro para
esa presencia extranjera en Irak por
ahora porque los necesitan no es así
el Consejo de Seguridad nacional dirige
este asunto
e identificará los sectores involucrados
en la cooperación en la lucha contra el
grupo de estado islámico y la
preservación de la soberanía de Irak
write
no le preocupa que algunos de los grupos
que forman su coalición hayan dicho que
están totalmente en contra de que
Estados Unidos permanezca en
iracuy hemos visto que algunos de ellos
han atacado las bases donde están los
soldados estadounidenses
o tiene garantías de que no volverá a
ocurrir el modo
ante todo la postura oficial de todas
las fuerzas políticas estén dentro o
fuera del parlamento o en el gobierno y
fuera de este
Haz que el parlamento no permitirá
tropas de combate en suelo ir aquí por
la soberanía de iraq
Y esa es la postura general
de acuerdo político entre todas las
fuerzas políticas también Afirma lo
mismo nuestra postura es muy clara en
nuestra Visión Es aún más clara para
este delicado asunto este tema es muy
importante para garantizar la seguridad
y la soberanía de Irak
y es una exigencia popular y
constitucional
hemos visto que las tensiones entre
Estados Unidos se Irán han aumentado las
conversaciones sobre cuestiones
nucleares entre occidente e Irán no van
a ninguna parte occidente le ha impuesto
nuevas sanciones a Irán a causa del
movimiento de protestas en el país de
Ucrania etcétera
A veces se ha llevado la peor parte de
estas tensiones
teme que la escalada entre Estados
Unidos se Irán pueda volver a ser un
problema para los iraquíes directamente
en su suelo
cualquier pensión que se produzca entre
Estados Unidos e Irán o entre los países
de la región repercutirá negativamente
en Irak
el
valle por eso nuestro gobierno está
adoptando una política exterior
equilibrada para continuar manteniendo
buenas relaciones con nuestros países
hermanos y vecinos
[Música]
del respeto y sin interferir en sus
asuntos internos
no quiere ser parte del enfrentamiento
no quiere que el suelo iraquí sea un
lugar para ajustar cuentas
el
gobierno irá aquí Busca la seguridad la
estabilidad y el desarrollo
creemos que es la solución es la clave
para la seguridad de todas las religión
Estamos buscando el rol positivo
este rol debería centrarse en la
creación de un sistema regional que se
ajuste a estas cooperaciones
estratégicas de desarrollo
Irak ha organizado reuniones entre Irán
y Arabia Saudita sin embargo la última
tuvo lugar en abril
usted ha dicho que espera que esta
reunión se repitan pero dada las
tensiones regionales de las que acabamos
de hablar
tiene garantías de ambas partes que
volverán a reunirse bajo de tutela de
Irak
desde el primer día que ocupé el cargo
me tomé muy en serio este asunto y la
convergencia de puntos de vista entre la
República islámica de Irak y el reino de
Arabia Saudita y las demás naciones
árabes
ya que nos interesa mucho mantener esta
relación esta cooperación con el fin de
desescalar las tensiones en la región
para lograr la seguridad
tenemos garantías de estos países y
continuamos con nuestros esfuerzos
pronto organizaremos una reunión en
Bagdad
cree que eso ocurrirá pronto en las
próximas dos semanas
en las próximas semanas ambos países
están dispuestos a reanudar estas
reuniones bajo sus auspicios y también
estuvieron presentes en Bagdad dos
conferencias en amán se pudo hablar de
eso
y creo que hay un deseo de mantener esa
cooperación bajo la tutela de Irak
voz tanto Irán como Turquía han atacado
grupos kurdos dentro de Irak en la zona
fronteriza a veces provocando la muerte
de civiles
es esto aceptable para un país soberano
como Irak tener a sus vecinos lanzando
misiles a veces bombardeando con aviones
en el suelo
lo que quiero decir es que usted como su
Primer Ministro no se supone que debe
impedir esto
desde luego que no lo aceptamos tenemos
posiciones oficiales en contra algunas
de estas posturas se presentaron al
Consejo de Seguridad como informes y a
la ONU y se organizaron sesiones
rechazamos cualquier ataque a la
soberanía de Irak y buscaremos cualquier
medio diplomático para detener estas
violaciones
[Música]
creemos que el diálogo es la vía para
comunicarnos con Turquía e Irán y
resolver estas dificultades
hemos dialogado con los comités de
seguridad y también con los consejos de
seguridad nacional
hemos entrado en la presencia de
guardias fronterizos para asegurar las
fronteras y prevenir cualquier ataque
contra Irak especialmente de Turquía
creemos que mantenemos excelentes
relaciones con Turquía e Irán
y creo que este tipo de relaciones serán
la solución
de acuerdo con el principio de respeto a
la soberanía de Irak
ciudad
hablando de la región kurda desde hace
años hay tensiones con el gobierno
regional
las recientes decisiones del máximo
tribunal iraquí de suspender
esencialmente el traspaso de ingresos de
Bagdad a hervir han suscitado vivas
críticas por parte de los dirigentes
quienes dicen que esto podría amenazar
la relación la estabilidad política
usted ha dicho que quiere resolver este
asunto de una vez por todas Parece ser
una Misión Imposible ciertamente
el gobierno entró en el acuerdo político
que se incluye en el programa
ministerial votado por el parlamento
Durante los últimos tres meses en pro de
solucionar esta dificultad pendiente
desde hace mucho tiempo
ahora vamos a presentar la ley del
presupuesto que resolverá una gran parte
de esa transferencia financiera de
acuerdo con la ley y la Constitución
y vamos a trabajar en la ley de
hidrocarburos que organizará la relación
entre el Gobierno Federal y gobierno
Regional del kurdistán y también las
otras provincias productoras de petróleo
esto de acuerdo con la constitución
en mi calidad de jefe de gobierno me
interesa mucho satis las demandas de la
población ya sea en el kurdistán en
ámbar o invasora quien proporcionar los
salarios Esa es mi responsabilidad ética
y
moralgia
señor Primer Ministro Muchas gracias por
concedernos esta entrevista durante su
visita a París y gracias a todos por
vernos permanezcan en sintonía para más
noticias en France 24
[Música]